comment va mon peuple
blogolo c'est magnifique
j'espère m'en avec labatt est content
sa femme lui manque un petit peu
enfin beaucoup
je travaille sur un projet pour te faire
sujet almar julie alice la date terminal
remonte à 208 mois et quatre jours
elle n'est pas prête à se mêler non bien
sûr
on n'avait jamais connecter un pc à une
archive auparavant j'ai attendu très
longtemps et quelque chose là-bas
c'était elle
[Musique]
pourtant reçu la visite de la société
qui s'occupe des archives
il pense que pour vos beaux pourrait
être basée sur leur technologie
nous avons l'obligation user de la force
si nécessaire je suis évaluateurs de
risque et vous vous
c'est un risque
je sais ce que tu fais là dedans georges
je peux pas le faire c'est aussi simple
que ça je veux pas être enfermé dans une
boîte en jeu très bas
je voulais arranger les choses touré
pareil
j'élimine elle est parfaite
qui le rend qc - c'est ici chez toi
je vais il mettait pas un terme à vos
recherches
ils vont bien vous cherchez tu m'as
jamais les tic
qu'est ce qu'ils valent c'est toi qui
veulent